Um, I can't see a thing!
A face? A giant robot!
You won't find this
in the orientation book.
This is the ultimate multipurpose decisive
combat weapons system created by man.
The Artificial Human Evangelion.
Unit 01 of the series.
Built in complete secrecy,
this is mankind's very last trump card.
-This is part of my father's work?
-Correct.
It's been a while.
Father...
Launch the Eva.
Launch the Eva?
But Unit 00 is still grounded!
Wait, you want to use Unit 01?!
There's no other choice.
Wait just a second!
Rei's in no condition for that!
It's got no pilot!
He just arrived.
Are you serious?
-Shinji Ikari.
-Yes?
You're going to pilot it.
But it took even Rei Ayanami seven months
to synchronize with her Eva!
He literally just got here!
He couldn't possibly do it!
All I ask is that he sit in the cockpit.
Nothing more.
But...
Repelling that Angel
is our number one priority right now.
For that, we need anyone capable of
synchronizing with an Eva to try,
however remote the chances.
I shouldn't need to tell you this,
Capt. Katsuragi.
You're right.
Father... Why did you send for me?
For the reason you're thinking.
So you want me to get inside this
and fight that thing out there?
Correct.
I don't want to do that!
Why send for me after all this time?!
I thought you left me
because you didn't need me!
I do now, so I sent for you.
But why me?
Because it's impossible for anyone else.
It is for me, too. I've never seen
or heard of this thing before.
I can't possibly do it!
Learn how.
That's... That's impossible!
There's no way I can pilot this!
If you're going to pilot it, do it.
Otherwise, get out!
That bastard must have figured out
where we are.
Shinji, we don't have much time.
Get in.
No way. I just got here! This is crazy!
Tell me, Shinji. Why did you come?
Don't run away! Not from your father,
and especially not from yourself.
I know! But there's no way I can do this!